merci la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
Armand Martin merci monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Premier ministre depuis 3
ans vous avez réussi à réaliser la
prouesse d'augmenter massivement les
impôts sans réduire significativement
les déficits public comme le prouve le
dernier rapport de la Cour des comptes
depuis 3 ans vous avez ponctionné plus
de 80 milliards d'euros de pouvoir
d'achat directement auprès des Français
pourtant les déficit de l'État dérape de
10 milliards d'euros tandis que les
s'effondre de 10,5 milliards d'euros
dont près la moitié sur l'impôt sur le
revenu ce matraquage fiscal a eu un
effet dévastateur chez les classes
moyennes les retraité et pour les
familles qui subissent une véritable
mise à mal de notre politique familiale
depuis vendredi dernier les familles
savent à quelle sauce elles vont être
mangé à partir du 1er juillet c'est la
fin de l'universalité des allocations
familiales c'est une rupture grave des
principes de base de notre politique
familiale depuis 1945 pour de nombreuses
familles qui comptent sur les
allocations familiales pour financer une
partie des activités de leurs enfants ou
la cantine scolaire l'année 2015
s'annonce difficile cette nouvelle
mesure va avoir des conséquences
importantes pour les familles de la
classe moyenne qui ont déjà subi
l'abaissement du plafond du quotidien du
Coon familial le président Hollande
avait annoncé une grande réforme fiscale
où est-elle vous y avez renoncé et vous
faites subir aux familles votre
renoncement à engager les réformes
nécessaires à l'avenir de la France
c'est un manque de courage politique
Monsieur le Premier Ministre la
modulation des allocations familiales
s'ajoute à la liste des mesures
antiamille remise en cause du caution
familial fiscalisation desoration de
retraite au-dessus de trois enfants
remise en cause de la prestation
d'accueil du jeune enfant et du conangé
parentale et cetera quelle est la
prochaine étape du matraquage fiscal des
familles merci la parole est à Madame
Marie Solten ministre des Affaires
sociales de la santé et des droits des
femmes merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député je ne peux pas vous
laisser dire que le gouvernement
s'attaque aux classes moyennes et aux
familles des classes moyennes parce que
je veux vous rappeler monsieur le député
ce que vous savez fort bien c'est qu'à
compter du 1er juillet prochain les
allocations familiales vont être
modulées pour 90 % des familles je le
dis solennellement 90 % des familles
cela ne changera rien cela veut donc
dire qu'il y a 10 % des familles dont
les revenus sont supérieurs à 6000 € net
par mois qui vont voir leurs allocation
familiale modulée si pour vous monsieur
le député plus de 6000 € par mois
c'est-à-dire 10 % des familles 10 %
c'est les classes moyennes alors je ne
sais pas comment vous appréciez vous
analysez vous évaluez la situation de la
société française et à côté de cela
Monsieur le Député je veux vous rappeler
que le gouvernement a engagé une
politique forte parce que la politique
familiale ce n'est pas seulement des
allocations qui restent universell
puisqu'elles seront versées à toutes les
familles mais la politique familiale
c'est aussi permettre aux familles de
mieux concilier vie familiale et vie
professionnel en ouvrant des places
d'accueil pour les jeunes enfants c'est
un engagement fort du gouvernement qui
créent des places d'accueil avoir une
politique familiale forte c'est aussi
s'adresser aux familles monoparentales
revaloriser les prestations qui sont
pour les familles nombreuses modestes le
complément familial la location de
soutien familial qui vont être
revalorisé respectivement de 25 et de 50
% alors vous le voyez monsieur le député
le gouvernement à une politique
familiale forte ambitieuse universelle
et juste c'est cela à quoi nous sommes
attachés répondre aux besoins à tous les
besoins de toutes les familles de notre
pays merci Madame